well the sequel to one of my favorite
films of all time has finally come out
Fantasia mm this is what Walt Disney
originally wanted to do he want to
continue the Fantasia legacy by having
new movies come out but since the first
one didn't do so hot they decided to
scrap that idea however the popularity
for Fantasia kept building and they
decided to finally do a sequel years
later it's fantastic it's brilliant it's
stupid and lame it's new and inspiring
it's old and been done it's a creative
magical experience it's a complete
sellout by every means of the word so as
you can imagine my emotions run pretty
high with this movie but in keeping with
the Disney tradition the stuff that's
good is really really good I guess the
best way to go about it is just to talk
about the segments it starts off with
Beethoven's fifth symphony and they're
trying to do what they deal with the
first film by having the abstract art
try to match the music at times it does
but for the most part it's trying to
tell a story like how there's this mama
butterfly and this baby butterfly and
they try to get away from these evil
black butterflies and yeah if it's
trying to go abstract why are you trying
to put a coherent narrative to it and on
top of that sometimes a coherent
narrative doesn't match the music so it
doesn't even work in that sense but it's
got a few good visuals in there next we
have the Pines of Rome with the flying
whales this is awesome the CG makes the
size and weight of the whales just look
gigantic it matches the music perfectly
and on top of that it just builds and
builds at the end
in fact this probably would have been
better as the last one but you know what
can you do the story the tin soldier is
okay though like most Disney films they
change the ending around it matches the
music imagines to be a cute little fairy
tale Rhapsody in Blue is a new take not
only in music but in style too they take
sort of an Al Hirschfeld style to the
whole thing yeah it works really well
it matches the music nice and it's good
to see Disney try something new
especially with Fantasia the Flamingo
with a yo-yo yeah just say that out loud
there's a flamingo with a yo-yo that's
the focus of one of them
musical segments in a Fantasia movie
well you can guess my problem it's cute
but really you can see that on Tiny
Toons or something it doesn't seem like
Fantasia related think we play The
Sorcerer's Apprentice that's always fun
and then we get Donald's Ark which again
is funny and cute but let's face it
every time you hear that music you're
gonna think of graduation and it's kind
of distracting it gets a few laughs
though so I guess it works fine and the
last one is the Firebird suite again
some of Disney's best animation here
mixing some of their classic style of
animation
but also mixing some new stuff is it me
or does that sprite look very animation
well this one matches the music great it
looks great and it's a nice finale
though again the whales would have been
a little better but I'm just nitpicking
unfortunately we also have celebrity
appearances that's Steve Martin probably
at is worse can I have my violin please
ah thank you oh right boiled oh oh sorry
could I have another stick thingy please
we also have been Midler James Earl
Jones Angela Lansbury Penn & Teller L
forgot a Penn & Teller really it's like
when they invited beavis and butt-head
to the Oscars just something doesn't
seem right here some of them can add a
little bit of class and dignity but most
of them are just spending time either
congratulating what a great movie is
even before it's done and the rest of
them are just making really painful
jokes oh and camera back on me camera
back on me
yeah the look on that woman's face says
it all the original Fantasia had a
dignity to it like they were gonna treat
the audience seriously like hey this was
for adults we're not gonna talk down to
you this is some of the greatest music
ever written we worked really hard on
this and we're gonna treat it that way
here it's Steve Barton go eat you know
what you do too so on the whole Fantasia
2000 is pretty hit and miss let's be
honest the only major miss would
probably be the celebrities I can't
think of any musical segments where I
was just like wow that was awful I mean
even the ones that aren't very good are
just not very good by Fantasia standards
but they're still fine on their own and
as I said before the stuff that's good
is incredibly good this is some of
Disney's best animation in years it
allows them to just be creative do what
they want just let the animation breathe
there's a sense that there wasn't as
many limitations to this and you know
what it really does show half the time
the other half not so much so honestly
despite his flaws I still highly
recommend it is it the first film no do
any of them meet the power seriousness
of the first film no but some of them do
come close overall I really like it yeah
I hate sitting through the celebrities
and some of the other musical segments
as much as you do but the payoff it's
just too good of a payoff I say
definitely check it out just have the
fast four button not Stan line